le débat divise donc on l'aura compris
chez les professeurs les parents
d'élèves et les élèves eux mêmes alors
faut-il rendre hommage à fait mais elle
pâtit dans ses convictions dans les
établissements scolaires c'est l'objet
de notre face à face ce soir
[Musique]
est avec nous pour en parler ce soir
jean-marc chipeau porte-parole de debout
la france en direct avec nous bonsoir
jean marc flipo merci d'être avec nous à
vos côtés sur ce plateau les ronds de
fontaine porte-parole de fabien roussel
a le candidat du parti communiste à
l'élection présidentielle bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous hommage donc qu'un on
la nie prévu vendredi dans toutes les
écoles une minute de silence suivie d'un
temps de réflexion
il faut savoir que l'année dernière cet
hommage au professeur assassiné avait
été perturbée 793 fois selon un décompte
du ministère de l'éducation nationale
jean marc dupont doit craindre qu'il y
ait la même chose cette année un risque
de perturbation l'ordre lors de cet
hommage en tout cas c'est ce que vous
craignez vous on peut le redouter on
doit pas le craindre le sepa l'édicule
éducation nationale ne doit pas craindre
de rendre hommage à l'inde est l'un des
siens qui est tombé en défendant les
valeurs fondamentales de la république
que sont la liberté de conscience la
liberté d'expression la tolérance donc
sans commencent à craindre de rendre
hommage à des à des défenseurs de ces
valeurs là on a plus qu'à fermer tous
les établissements scolaires de france
non on peut le redouter en revanche et
malheureusement on prépare pas les
choses d'une bonne manière puisque dans
la manière dont ces recettes annoncées
le ministère de l'éducation nationale
parle d'un hommage qui peut aller
jusqu'à une heure c'est pas une heure
dommage c'est jusqu'à 1h dommage on
laisse les équipes décidées en fonction
je parle je peux vous dire de bêtises en
fonction de leur situation respective
c'est à dire qu'on fait fi des ja de
l'unité de l'enseignement et de
l'éducation nationale on considère qu'il
ya des enfants des établissements dans
lesquels on pourra pas faire on pourra
pas faire cet hommage et puis pardon
mais encore une fois quand je vois le
jeu voit en eux le texte de l'éducation
nationale qui parle d'une séquence
spécifique sur la construction esprit
critique ainsi que sur le métier de prof
son rôle sa légitimité c'est à dire que
dans l'énoncé même de l'hommage on va te
dis qu'on va discuter de la légitimité
des professeurs mais pardon moi je peux
pas entendre ça je ne peux pas entendre
qu'un gouvernement met une heure des
changes pour que les élèves et les
professeurs discutent de la légitimité
de des professeurs de l'éducation
on va passer la parole à léo de fontaine
mais tout d'abord je voudrais vous
rappeler à cette nouveauté à partir de
ce soir vous pouvez vous réagir sur
notre compte télégramme rt france pour
venir apporter un petit peu voilà deux
de nos moulins de ce débat donner votre
sentiment vos réactions léon de fontaine
vous partager la même je dirais
indignation que monsieur chipeau on a
pas à discuter de la légitimité du
professeur pendant cet hommage
sachant que également vous avez tout à
fait une autre approche moi je pense que
c'est cet hommage le meilleur moyen de
rendre hommage à samuel paty et à la
mission de l'enseignement c'est de
l'entretenir tout au long de l'année et
je pense qu'il faut pouvoir ouvrir des
discussions des échanges bien évidemment
tout au long de l'année avec les
enseignants sur ce que c'est que ce
métier ce beau métier que certains
appellent et que je appelle également le
plus beau métier du monde et pour cela
il faut pas les considérer que pendant
une heure il faut pas leur laisser la
place que pendant une heure et bien tout
au long de l'année et ça ça implique une
chose que le gouvernement n'a pas fait
c'est de pouvoir écouter aussi les
revendications qu'ils ont sur leurs
conditions de travail sur la
revalorisation de leur travail et je
pense que la priorité devrait être celle
ci et je pense que ce serait le meilleur
hommage justement à rendre à samuel
pâtit en tout cas vous avez été nombreux
déjà à réagir tout au long de la journée
un sur cette question qu'on m'a posée
faut-il rendre hommage à ces nouvelles
pâti dans ces conditions dans les
établissements scolaires on va voir une
de vos réponses ce débat ne fait
qu'alimenter la division au sein de la
population et pour qu'au final ce soit
ce gouvernement fantoche qu'il soit
gagnant est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec cette analyse de l'un de nos
téléspectateurs jean marc flipo
d'écouté de toute évidence ce débat va
être client mais maintenant on peut pas
je sais que je suis pas suspect de de
défendre de défendre le gouvernement
bien sûr cas on a vu dans votre
reportage il ya déjà des clivages qui se
sont créés entre le gouvernement et les
parents d'élèves mais pour autant on
peut pas on peut pas renoncer à
honorer ce qui constitue les valeurs
cardinales de notre république jean
michel blanquer a déclaré récemment que
l'assassinât de leurs humeurs de
sympathie était un une insulte à la
démocratie c'est pas une insulte à la
démocratie c'est la démocratie qu'on
assassine
c'est la république qu'on assassine et
face à ça je suis désolé il faut faire
bloc il en va effectivement peut-être se
compter on va compter les gens qui font
bloc derrière les valeurs de la
république encore une fois des valeurs
de liberté de conscience de liberté
d'expression des valeurs de tolérance et
puis on va compter ceux qui sont pas
d'accord avec ça et ça c'est le vrai
problème qui va falloir régler
effectivement dans les haies dans les
semaines les mois d habitude à léon de
fontaine il y à ce malaise justement
dans l'éducation nationale aujourd'hui à
parler
l'assassinât d'une victime à son bon
sens d'un enseignant au nom d'une
religion il faut prendre à bras le corps
ce problème aujourd'hui dans le pays
clairement bien sûr qu'il faut prendre à
bras le corps mais je réagis aussi à
l'intervention précédentes je pense pas
qu'il s'agit de l'ordre de sauteuses cet
hommage de se compter il s'agit surtout
de regarder comment on fait en effet
l'unité comment on fait bloc comment on
arrive à rassembler l'ensemble des
acteurs de l'éducation pour pouvoir
justement rendre hommage non seulement à
samuel paty et faire vivre sa mémoire en
faisant vivre l'éducation nationale
comme institution républicaine garante
des libertés et moi je pense que ce
serait désastreux de montrer du doigt
justement celles et ceux qui n'auraient
pas été très propre dans un adam des
agissements qui aurait permis qui
peuvent être montrés du doigt le
critiquer je pense qu'au contraire il
faut regarder comment l'école
l'éducation nationale est inclusive et
arrive à inclure l'ensemble des citoyens
parce que si on n'arrive pas à faire ça
et qu'on commence à créer des divisions
alors malheureusement malheureusement je
pense qu'on passera à côté de cet
hommage et surtout à côté de ce que
samuel patty a essayé de faire tout au
long de son travail
justement dans la lignée de ce que nous
dit allez on de fontaines 1 voilà on
venait de voir un tweet cake disparu
mais j'ai essayé de le retrouver
effectivement si on peut me le remettre
à l'instant c'est pas grave enfin en
gros on parlait de voilà ne risque-t-on
pas de provoquer une nouvelle division
entre les pour et les contre et de
générer de la violence voire un climat
de guerre civile je rebondis aussi sur
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure jean
marc flipo voilà il faut se compter il
n'ya pas toujours
cette espèce de climat très clivant qui
semble devenir un petit peu le la de
cette campagne présidentielle qui se
lance
mais pardon mais quand on parle de
violence qu'est ce qu'il ya de plus
violent que la décapitation d'un
enseignant je voudrais qu'on m'explique
si ça c'est pas de l'ultra violence
alors ça veut dire tout ça on en a perdu
le sens des mots ensuite il s'agit pas
ne s'agit pas de diviser jeu on va se
compter parce que c'est ce qui se
passera dans les faits c'est bien
évidemment pas un sou s pas un projet ça
peut pas en être le projet bien
évidemment ces deux de rétablir cette
république que l'on aime qui est une et
indivisible
l'ensemble dans tous ces territoires
dans toutes ses composantes
moi je remarque pour être un peu plus
léger peut-être je remarque dans la
vidéo on voit pas toutes les vidéos sur
l'agression de l'enseignante de combs la
ville moi je remarque que dans la vidéo
malgré ce bazar ambiant lac avec des
élèves qui sont enlevés pour la
secourir pour la relever donc tout n'est
pas perdu il ya effectivement un énorme
un énorme travail à faire mais en
attendant il ya des choses qui sont
dites ligne rouge on ne peut pas
franchir or je suis désolé l'hommage à
sa belle platine en tout cas pour moi
c'est un marqueur fort le gouvernement
ne peut pas faire l'économie de cela je
suis désolé mais d'une manière ou d'une
autre il faut que ce message passe dans
la tête de tout un chacun et ceux qui
sont réfractaires à ce message s'est dit
quelque chose et il faudra il faudra
s'en occuper pardon mais si les faits
les faits sont têtus alors il ya
justement cet autre débat dans le débat
qui touche finalement c'est le débat de
fond est le pourquoi de l'assassinât de
sa nouvelle patrie il a trouvé la mort
nous dit sandrine c'est après avoir
voulu éveillé ses élèves sur la
tolérance et le droit au blasphème on en
revient à ce thème qui est assez
récurrent
vous avez la même analyse que ses
téléspectatrices qui qui vous écris ce
soir oui bien sûr mais je pense que
l'éducation à un rôle une mission c'est
pas uniquement former les travailleurs
de demain s'est formée et à former les
citoyens de demain permettre
l'épanouissement et la libération la du
carcan religieux familiale philosophique
conclure nous inculquer à nos parents et
ouvrir aussi les esprits et je pense que
c'est un des rôles fondamental de
l'éducation nationale malheureusement
avec les moyens qu'elle a actuellement
on a tendance à déléguer sarraut médecin
au second plan or je pense qu'il faut
justement réfléchir peut être repenser
les missions de l'éducation nationale
pour justement revenir aux fondamentaux
et notamment permettre à chaque élève et
à chaque enseignant de pouvoir
éduquer former les élèves les instruire
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
et pour cela il faut qu on pose les
vrais sujets aujourd'hui il ya trop d
effectifs par classe le métier
d'enseignement et malheureusement
dévaloriser notamment au niveau du
salaire et je pense qu'il faudrait un
des meilleurs zonage comprennent en
assam elle pâtit c'est justement de
revaloriser ce plus beau ce beau métier
d'enseignant et ça ça implique de
dédoubler les classes de redonner du
sens on dédoublant les classes pas plus
de 25 élèves par classe de recruter des
enseignants partout sur le territoire
pour offrir la meilleure instruction à
nos jeunes aux nouvelles générations aux
enfants ça passe également par augmenter
le temps à l'école aussi pour permettre
justement de répondre à toutes ses
missions et nous c'est bien l'ambition
que nous portons avec la condamnation
aussi de fanions cela vous êtes allés au
delà effectivement de ce débat en parler
aussi du droit au blasphème puisque
c'est aussi l'un des aspects de ce débat
je voudrais à ce propos justement vous
montrer une étude ifop réalisée au
printemps dernier sur la place de la
religion pour les lycéens et bien
regardez 52 % des lycéens conteste la
liberté de se montrer irrespectueux
vis-à-vis d'une religion et de ses
dogmes le droit au blasphème est donc
clairement contestée par les lycéens
français jean marc flipo ça vous inspire
quoi on devient comme aux états unis
justement et les faits peut vous étonner
de la part des jeunes justement ce
sentiment
ça m'étonne de la moyennement de la part
du jeune puisque c'est on voit bien
qu'il ya une vague de plus en plus
importants justement de comment dire de
prosélytisme de prosélytisme religieux
pendant qu'on avant on en abandonnant
certaines certaines valeurs
chrétiennes à l'islam qui est venu
s'imposer avec tous encore plus le
l'islam c'est un projet de loi qui
concerne tous les jeunes a les mêmes
jeunes d'ailleurs peut-être on dit
souvent on le rappelle qui dans les
sondages peut-être s'intéresse à eric
zemmour et marine le pen a oui tout à
fait mais enfin je vous donnais à
49 % des enseignants en suite à
l'assassinât de sa belle bâtisse à une
étude qui a été établi en décembre 2020
49% des enseignements déclarait s'auto
censurer et ne pas rentrer dans leurs
enseignements de comment dire de des
programmes d prenant religieux donc déjà
déjà les enseignants eux-mêmes
s'autocensurent il faut pas s'étonner
que derrière avec la pression globale
qu'on assure sur justement le fait
religieux maintenant en france faut pas
s'étonner qu'on arrive à des à des
chiffres pareils au sein des lycéens
maintenant il ya effectivement
l'éducation doit doit pouvoir remplir
son rôle pour qu'elle puisse remplir son
rôle il ya un préalable qui est
incontournable c'est d'assurer la
sécurité des enseignants et la sueur et
le calme dans les classes or à l'heure
actuelle si vous voyez là l'intégralité
de la vidéo de combs-la-ville justement
vous voyez qu'avant même incident c'est
c'est tout sauf de calme dans la classe
j'entendais 7 cette personne qui disait
qu'il y avait pas de on écoutait pas les
élèves
mais c'est complètement délirant
regardez cette vidéo il vous verrez le
bazar intégral qu'il ya dans cette place
c'est pas de la faute de l'enseignant
c'est le quotidien des enseignants ado
bout la france en a beaucoup
d'enseignants qui nous remontent qui
nous font tous remonter les mêmes
informations ce qui s'est passé à
combs-la-ville c'est pas quelque chose
d' isoler c'est le quotidien des
enseignants et danses et des enseignants
qui sont livrés à eux mêmes qu'ils ne
sont pas soutenus par leur hiérarchie à
chaque fois qu'ils veulent dénoncer des
faits de
l'agressivité on leur dit non quand vous
êtes vous êtes dans l'excès vous
l'interprété telle ou telle chose et à
tel point qu'en 2018 il y avait un autre
on va dire un autre incident qui était
encore plus grave qui s'était déroulée à
créteil où un élève avait braqué un
pistolet sur la tête de l'un de ses
professeurs sont heureusement un
pistolet factice mais ça avait donné
lieu à l'époque au hashtag pas de vagues
les enseignants avaient mis en ligne sur
twitter le hashtag pas de vagues parce
qu'il se sentait totalement abandonné 2
lors de leur hiérarchie et il pouvait
pas remonter les informations et déjà à
l'époque en 2018 on avait des grands
coups de menton tantôt de jean michel
blanquer en tout cas de gabriel attal je
disais comment on va on va remettre la
sécurité dans les classes vous allez
voir la primauté au respect des
professeurs on est trois ans trois
années plus tard il s'est produit à
l'est on défend très justement quand on
entend cette maman vire oui en gros en
substance un jeu je résume effectivement
c'est la faute des professeurs il n'y a
pas d' écoute ça vous choque vous dites
il ya un an maintenant de respect de la
fonction peut-être
de professeurs et que les voilà c'était
un discours qui peut vous vous choquer
les 110 courtier qui est choquant à quoi
je pense que le problème ne vient pas de
l'éducation nationale en tant que tel
mais du ministère de l'éducation
nationale aussi qui a sa part de
responsabilité parce qu'en fait cela
fait maintenant un certain nombre
d'années qu'on entend ce discours sur
les enseignants sont les profs sur le
fait qu' il serait trop payés qu'eux ils
ne travaillent pas assez suffisamment 38
moi je on l'a entendu mais de moins en
moins et fort heureusement quand on voit
le salaire d'un enseignant quand il
commencera en carrière et même à la fin
de sa carrière mais en fait derrière le
salaire et la valeur comporte
aujourd'hui aux métiers sont deux choses
qui sont liés or le gel du point
d'indicé
cela fait maintenant de nombreuses
années qu'on demande à ce qu'il soit
levé et que les fonctionnaires est un
salaire qu'ils soient plus élevés nous
propose l'augmentation de 30% des
salaires mais on propose aussi de
redonner du sens à ce boulot parce
qu'aujourd'hui malheureusement il ya
aussi une perte de sens pour toute la
société de ce que c'est que ce boulot et
donc pour cela il faut faire des
meilleures conditions de travail qui
offriront de meilleures conditions
d'études et c'est ça qui permettront de
de revaloriser ce métier pas uniquement
auprès des lycéens des collégiens ou des
de l'ensemble de la jeunesse mais bien
dans l'ensemble de la société et moi je
pense que c'est important essentiel et
bien évidemment il faut avoir un
ministère qui puisse soutenir l'ensemble
de son équipe pédagogique l'ensemble des
enseignants est aujourd'hui
malheureusement force est de constater
que ce n'est pas le cas parce qu'ils les
méprise lorsqu'ils sortent dans la rue
lorsqu'ils manifestent lorsqu'ils
revendiquent ils les méprisent il refuse
de les écouter écoutons ce qu'on a à
dire ces enseignants et regardons avec
eux construisons avec eux un projet
politique global pour l'éducation
nationale qui permettent d'offrir non
seulement les meilleures conditions de
travail et surtout la meilleure
instruction pour la jeunesse merci
beaucoup léon de fontaine jean marc
flipo d'avoir été avec nous devra
accepter ce face à face et merci à vous
pour toutes vos réactions sur télégramme
rt france vous pourrez le faire
évidemment tous les soirs à l'occasion
de nos face-à-face quotidien merci